bro
it wouldn't let me move I couldn't grab
the queen
oh my God both
bad streamer rating and bad bullet
rating I mean that was really bad just
check
and then Bishop C4 ah Rook C2 maybe it
was not so clear
why couldn't I move it
I tried to grab the queen it didn't let
me
oh boy
oh boy
anyway now flag two cars second dude
eyes clear first congrats to to them
especially to um to those as well as
jigayv finished
in third place
what happened I just couldn't pull so
let me see like
Queen E3 obviously it was winning before
but I did a good job keeping the game
going
let me see like if I take
this
I cannot escape with the King yeah I
cannot Escape
so and if I go the other way there's
rookie four
uh
can I take with the bishop
this is a fascinating position
I take her the Knight no it's not clear
C6 was a sick move
Rook D1
yeah can I go Bishop S3 because the
Knight F5
so
here Knight C4
this is not clear
and here you could have taken him
could have taken this
a check take this Rook C3
so I have to go like this which is
probably a draw but I'm worth
now this
go back okay Bishop C6 is a weird move
but who cares here I was almost lagging
but yeah this is
why I mean
why was I not
icing to grab the queen I feel like
there was
something weird happening there I mean
it was a super messy game so it was not
unfair that he won I mean we both missed
chances I just that was just really
for this change